if there was one
coin outside of a fun one
not a bitcoin not an ethereum a fun coin
a fun coin from everyone on the thing
what
fun coin do you like is it come rocket
is it [ __ ] coin is it ascoin
i i think the coins that are
uh donating to charity
you know as a part of their that's a
part of their donating
i like that charity is relying upon
come rocket for donations i think that's
a good system
we have but are there coins donating to
charity
yeah there's like there's there's pit
bully for example where
you know a lot a large part of their
liquidity gets donated to
prevent against bullying wait what's the
name of that
pit bully pit bully yeah
and wait a minute
it has nothing to do with pit bulls
i think the logo is a pit bull okay
it's a violent dog now so
part of the their liquidity gets donated
to bullies
i like that and it took they give it or
no it's donated to the victims of
bullying
correct yeah okay
so oh tim well i'm glad
what about you guys is there any fun
coin do you have any fun with the coins
you're so respected and legitimate say
something
insane so that we can get views so i
don't fire my [ __ ] agent
for sending me down here i'm kidding
it's been fun we've had a lot of fun i i
like
i like this it feels deeply like a
religion
now which is healthy i think it is
i think mass psychosis is good
and other people don't but i think
there's something nice about a group of
people
who believe things no matter what no
matter what the facts are
it's good to have a group of people
completely impervious to any logic
or outside information i think it's good
now are there any other coins that you
guys have fun with
i mean i tweet about doge a lot but i
don't know any
so you don't own any dogecoin not yet
what about you
no what about you jake i mean you got
i mean i think everyone messes around
with with
[ __ ] coins a little bit yeah but i i was
in doge yeah before elon talked about it
right [ __ ] coins are like [ __ ]
but
not sex workers which are great [ __ ]
sex workers it's a legit we get it but
so the [ __ ] goes like [ __ ] and
but you married the bitcoin and then you
also that's what you do you marry
the bitcoin and then you [ __ ] ethereum
once a year
and your wife doesn't mind because you
have a pool
that's kind of am i wrong about that
i think i'm kind of right about that
well we're going to wrap this up soon
because there's an after party
uh where uh elon will show up if elon
had balls he would come to this
convention
i i believe that right
man this audience has the energy of the
capital riot
i mean it's like i'm so scared that
there's not a [ __ ] glass partition
between these two security guys what are
they gonna do
these people just storm the stage and
[ __ ] kill us all
they'll tweet about it like yeah that
sucked anyway
jake paul's getting eaten alive by some
[ __ ] crypto freaks
in a [ __ ] convention center i'm glad
we can't afford a real convention center
we're here in this [ __ ] weird art
installation
nothing makes you feel good about the
future of a financial product and
walking by [ __ ] white chicks with
dreadlocks on the street
who are painting [ __ ] murals on the
[Music]
wall
it's like the fed versus street art it's
like great
good next year we'll get the real
convention center
any parting words of wisdom this is an
army of people out there they're they're
maybe losing faith in bitcoin
maybe they've lost money who knows
is there any anything that you guys can
say is your final closing argument of
like hey
times are tough they might get tougher
is there anything you because you guys
are relatable figures
you're billionaire tall athletic
olympians
just like everyone else in this country
now so talk to your equals out there
your equals that are watching you on
youtube going those guys and me
we get it friends of mine
unemployed uber drivers morbidly obese
drug addicts people that own
1 18th of a bitcoin and look at you and
go i'm going to be them
even your last name is kind of magical a
little bit
winklevoss it just sounds if i said that
was my last name somebody would go
no it's not they'd go no it's not
and i'd go you're right so is there any
inspiring message you have
for the monsters out there on the other
end of their
screen looking at you going bitcoin's my
way out what do you say to them
always stack sats and remember to always
huddle
and buy the dip and buy the dead
okay jake what words of wisdom do you
have for
people on tick tock right now that are
going to be irrelevant in 15 minutes
who who want to start fighting people
because it's their only hope
they go i gotta fight people now
i mean you and your brother are like
you're like the leaders of that
that section of the internet where it's
like now everybody's fighting
tick tockers youtubers the demilio girls
are kicking each other in the face
what do you what do you tell people who
want to have a career on the internet as
you've had
what do you tell those people out there
because you're a relatable guy
you were you grew up in ohio you were a
landscaper
and now you own the island of puerto
rico so what do you say to those people
i would say uh
you're [ __ ] i'd say don't do it yeah
don't do it don't do it
that's what i tell them about comedy
don't do it stick to your day job
well that's an inspiring message i could
say something inspiring but i wouldn't
that's what i like that's what i love
about you you're not full of [ __ ]
you don't tell people it's gonna work
out
you did a lot of [ __ ] you jumped on a
lot of trampolines you grabbed a lot of
hats
you [ __ ] worked your ass off you know
these people rode a lot everyone worked
what is this guy this guy's do you have
a gun i'm kidding anyway
[Laughter]
this is this is a terrifying audience
this is the scariest audience
i've i've performed it like heavy metal
concerts
and this audience is much scarier
belief in anything is really terrifying
that's what i've learned you know but i
love i love being here i think bitcoin
is going to bounce back
i say it's wrong that people call it a
financial q anon
i think i
you suck
listen buddy you you're a good person
and you're angry and i don't know why
you're angry but
it's probably because you're involved in
a cult
and you need to get out of that cult and
do something else
the meaning that you're looking for in
life you're not going to find in a
convention center in miami
that's not even real right after you
people leave they move the homeless
right back in here
truly right after you guys leave they
move homeless people back in here and
then they get up here and talk about
bitcoin
that's all that happens but anyway thank
you that's give it up for elon musk's
brother
that's e that's kimble musk everybody